[Music]
hi my name is Sean Govardhan I'm a
strategic cloud engineer from Sydney
Australia on stage I have Henry Surya
where Wan who's also a strategic cloud
engineer from Singapore and we have one
of our cloud partners in Gopi code
Ravalli he is he's based here in in the
US so we're really excited to be here to
be talking about how you can build some
really cool innovative Internet of
Things applications using cloud files to
cloud file store is the next-generation
document-oriented database built
specifically for the cloud it allows you
to spin up real time stateful
applications in a matter of minutes it
is so easy it allows you to keep your
data in sync across multiple devices
even when they're offline we'll get into
more details very soon so this session
is really about building real-time
stateful applications but what exactly
do we mean by stateful stateful
essentially means that the computer or
program keeps track of the state of
interactions by setting values in a
storage field designated for that
purpose so we're going to look at the
architectural choices and technical
considerations in building an Internet
of Things application from the ground up
from scratch and we're gonna marvel at
the ease of use and simplicity of
firestorm whose use fire still here yay
who likes fires to everybody right yeah
so look fundamentally you know it allows
you to keep your data and sync across
multiple devices and you know you can
you can literally spin up biote
applications in a matter of minutes
we're gonna explore our state some of
the architectural choices and technical
considerations in building an IOT
application marvel at the ease of use
and simplicity of fire stool so with
that IOT is really made up of
intelligence it's really about people
applique
and devices working together to deliver
a smart experience you know the
smartphone you know is a perfect example
of an IOT device it allows us to convert
data to information smart IOT devices
take it to a whole new level they allow
us to convert data to information
information to knowledge knowledge to
wisdom and use the wisdom to make
meaningful decisions that will improve
the quality of our lives
they probably allow us to glean
actionable insights in the moments that
matter in the moments of commercial
intent so really speaking of devices you
know it's really important for us to
understand the subtle distinction
between a microcontroller and a
microprocessor a microcontroller or an
MCU they tend to be fairly less
expensive they are simpler to set up
simpler to operate and you know Arduino
ESP 32 particle are some examples of
microcontrollers a connected coffee
machine for instance only needs to
concern itself with simple routines and
tasks so a microcontroller is perfectly
suited for that use case a
microprocessor on the other hand you
know they tend to be a little bit more
expensive the Raspberry Pi is a great
example of a microprocessor so you know
they allow you to install a full fledged
operating system and they you know they
provide features like package management
it can install additional software and
stuff and they also allow multitasking
so robotics drones augmented reality are
some typical use cases of where you
would use and deploy micro processors
and it's really important to understand
the difference between micro controllers
and micro processors because the tools
techniques and protocols that will be
used to develop the application will
decide you know whether you'd be
deploying it on a microcontroller or
microprocessor so that fundamental
decision will determine
what tools technologies and protocols
you'll be using
so with that I'll quickly hand over to
Henry who'll be talking about Firestone
Thank You Sean
so at the heart of this demo is actually
called firestorm so what is cloud
firestorm to put it simply cloud
firestore is a service no sequel
document database that is built for the
cloud but it's much more than that
cloud firestore is more of a back end as
a service that not only gives you the
data base but also provides the
infrastructure that handles moving
stateful data between the cloud and your
application and devices which naturally
leads us into how it's also an embedded
database that continues to power your
application and devices to the cloud so
let's dive deeper into cloud file scope
as mentioned it's a document oriented
database which means that it's designed
to store and manage semi structured data
such as JSON objects it's completely
schema-less meaning that you don't need
to design your schema upfront so that
you can continue to evolve your
application without having to worry
about you know coordinating structural
changes to your database and you can
update your application as and when you
need it Google fully manages the
infrastructure for you so that you can
focus on building your application
rather than you know thinking about
scheduling downtime so install your
database upgrades or even like
installing the latest security
vulnerability vulnerability patches it
gives you a full civilus experience so
that you don't need to think about
machine sizes like CPU rams number of
nodes replicas this or even networking
all of these are packaged with
pay-as-you-go pricing that can scale
down to zero when you don't need it
Cloud firestore is super simple to set
up you enable it from your project
download and install the SDK in your
apps and then you're ready to go like I
said it's more than just a database you
can access it directly from your
application without
having to write any middle tier that
sits in between we can secure this
direct connection with a combination of
decorative security rules and
integration with firebase authentication
what these rules allow is that it can it
can it can manage the you know like the
request that comes in to fire stock you
can allow it or deny it based on what
the request is who the sign-on user is
and how it compares with the information
stored in the database and what makes
firestorm more than just a database is
the real-time update capability
firestore doesn't give you just the
database but also handles the pushing of
the updates synchronization of the
changes from the database with your app
in real time so we're going to see that
in a demo as well which brings me to the
last embedded database piece 5s SDKs for
the file store actively cache data in
your app so that you can write read
listen to your query data even when the
device is offline
the mobile and JavaScript SDKs for iOS
Android and browsers give you the local
embedded database that syncs with the
cloud when there's an active connection
and it also has this nifty feature
called latency compensation which
basically handles pushing of the updates
to the cloud ok and then I'm blocking
the UI and also giving you more freedom
in your app talking about firebase SDKs
there are some crucial components that
are also included inside the first is
firebase authentication which supports
signing in user based on passwords phone
numbers and other popular identity
providers such as Google Facebook
Twitter or github security rules as
mentioned provide access control and
data validation in a simple and yet
expressive format cloud functions
lets you configure events such as when
you add new document to your collection
and you can trigger a function from
there so it lets you extend your
application even further into the cloud
we have implemented some core functions
for the demo later on for the real
object detection system and we're gonna
see it shortly next Club firebase cloud
messaging
lets you reliably deliver messages at no
cost
and lastly firebase remote conflict it
allows you to change the behavior of
your app without requiring users to
download an app update you can use this
for scenarios such as a/b testing dark
launches canary release or feature
toggle and cloud file store is not just
for firebase project you can use it for
server-side as well it supports multiple
server-side languages like C sharp Java
algo and so on and so forth it supports
both rests and G RPC api's making it
accessible from any environment it's
designed for reliability with 5/9
availability target the multi region
replication ensures that your data is
durable and highly available even in the
face of the natural disasters and it can
scale on demand based on you know like
the most demanding workloads that you
have so that you don't need to think
about like connection pools and it's
highly suited for scalable compute
infrastructure such as kubernetes an
engine or App Engine and you can both
scale up when you need it or scale down
when you don't need it so I'll hand over
to Gopi who will run through the
architecture and implementation of our
demo yeah thanks Andy
so let's look at the architecture and
implementation right so if you look at
this we're actually using firebase
firebase is like a Swiss Army knife
right sis it has a file store it gives
you a storage it gives you cloud
function it gives you hosting and it
also give you a tent occation and
authorization capabilities right so what
we're doing here is we have an IOT
device which captures data telemetry
data from the sensors mounted on the
grow pi plus and it pushes the data in
real time to cloud file store right on
you on the other hand the picture
captured from the camera module is
pushed to the cloud storage right which
is basically fied firebase storage so
firebase storage is essentially a Google
Cloud storage location which is
accessible through firebase administer
case so
the picture pictures keep arriving in
the firebase storage we actually written
a simple cloud function that gets
triggered the cloud function basically
invokes which an API calls right and all
it does is it detects objects within the
image and a sense labels to the detected
objects
so all these outputs are basically
written back to the cloud file store and
the UI the user interface basically is
hosted using firebase hosting and all
the authentication is basically done
using firebase authentication so there
are a lot of providers which you can use
so right now in our demo application we
are using Google Cloud or sign-in for
authorization we're actually writing
security rules for all the authorizing
access to services like five stores
storage etcetera right so that's the
simplistic version of the architecture
that we have developed so you can
basically extend this simple
architecture to interact with your own
suite of machine learning services so if
you look at the machine learning
spectrum on the left hand side you have
a whole range of ease of use services
like vision api's or if you want to
extend it more customize it to your use
case you can basically use cloud or
table or you can further customize build
your own bring your node bring your own
data build your own models using a cloud
machine learning engine right so how
many of you like Python in your raise
your hands I like Python how many of you
like node.js okay and how many of you
like go and how many of you don't like
any of these right so what what we have
done is the cloud function that we have
developed the initial version was in
Python 2 right and it was it was all
traditional synchronizing traditional
synchronous calls so if you look at the
components in order Python cloud
function we basically have four four
major tasks which is an object detection
a label detection a web entity detection
and a URL generation right so what we
have done is we have taken the initial
version of the Python code developed by
sham and we have kind of made it a
synchronous
using node.js you can as well make it as
synchronous using Python 3 using a sync
i/o and if you are a go programmer you
can basically use go routines right so
so this is the a synchronous
representation of the of the cloud
function that we have developed and if I
did I have deep into each of the
functions within the cloud function
right so this is a simple function for
object localization all it does is it
takes the image input from the GCS
bucket write it instantiate an object of
cloud which an API and all it receives
is coordinates of the bounding boxes
which are just the vertices of the
bounding boxes right that's what we get
as response out of object localization
the next API is we are actually using
object localization so which is
sorry--but label detection which is
basically assigning labels based on the
objects that are detected within the
image and and the third one is web
entity direction so for the for the
image that you actually give it as input
it actually searches on the web and
gives you labels for the image and
finally we have a function for
generating sign URLs for the images from
cloud storage so that we can populate
that on topic onto the UI so if you
observe in in node.js what we are using
is where you we are implementing
promises right so basically your promise
objects once they get resolved in a null
synchronous fashion we actually collect
all the responses create an image
document which has all the responses
from object detection to label detection
to web entity detection to your you
signed URL and we basically write this
object inside a predefined collection in
cloud 5 store all right so let's look at
the demo great who is a hundred percent
believer that live demos at large
conferences in front of large audiences
always work well obviously we're gonna
find out very soon so you know what
you're looking at here is a smart
environment monitor
and an object detection system so
essentially it's a rig that I put up
together and it features a Raspberry Pi
3 model b+ who's play played with one of
these many of you ok good
who's played with a sense hat good a few
of you so you see the Raspberry Pi 3
model b+ has those GPIO pins at the top
the sense hat here is unit comes with a
bunch of sensors but the ones that I was
particularly interested in is a
gyroscope and an accelerometer so what
you can do is essentially take the
Raspberry Pi and the sensor you know
connect them both together like so using
the GPIO pins yeah and the third piece
to the puzzle is what's known as a Grove
pipe plus you know you can pick up the
Raspberry Pi 3 model b+ for about 35 US
dollars since has since since that is
about the same cost as well and this
thing here grows by pluses from seed
studio and it comes with a few you know
connectors that allow you to hook up
sensors so you have three analog sensors
connectors to the left you have digital
sensors at the connectors at the bottom
and you also have other eye to see
connectors on the right as well so
essentially you know the sense hat and
the growth pipe plus I essentially known
as hats Hardware attached at the top so
you can literally take it and hook it up
directly on top of one another just like
so and what I've ended up with is
basically exactly what I've described
over there and what I also have is a
bunch of sensors connected to the entire
rig so I have a light sensor on the top
left-hand corner
it basically detects fluctuations in the
light levels the sound sensor
like us in like obviously detects the
fluctuations in the sound level the
angle sensor it's a knob it basically
allows you to twist it left or right and
I'm using it to control the rate of
transmitting telemetry data to the
firestore you know essentially it's a
potentiometer in electronics terms so
when you turn it full all you know all
the way up it sends it fast and when you
turn it down it sends it slower so and
here you basically have a flame sensor I
was told that I couldn't light a match
or a lighter here on stage for safety
reasons say it ain't gonna happen you
also have a button here as well when you
press the button the web camera will
take a photo and there is an ultrasonic
sensor and that sensor basically checks
the proximity reading so as you move an
object further or closer to it
it will detect that and what actually
happens is all of these readings get
uploaded transmitted to Firestone in
real time and that's the beauty about it
what use is an environment monitor if
it's not in real time you don't want to
know that your house is on fire five
minutes ago you want to know if it
anything is happening right this very
moment so real time nature is critical
and it's for that very reason I felt
that fire store was a perfect fit I
can't think of any other solution
that'll give me that feature and
functionality so essentially this is
basically what my first version looked
like I plugged in all those sensors and
as it says here my first version also
used Google IOT core and Google pops
Arbus world pub/sub is an asynchronous
message broking platform from Google
which is part of Google cloud platform
and Google IOT core allows you to create
a device registry a central registry of
all your IOT devices for this particular
use case you know I just talked with
firestore because it was much simpler to
demo
and this here was the final version of
what I ended up so the previous version
of the smart environment monitor only
featured the six sensors the next
version also included a logitech webcam
connected to the USB port of the
Raspberry Pi and I also connected a
speaker to it in this instance I
actually have the audio connected to the
central audio speakers there I also have
a little travel router here so the
entire rig basically gets its IP address
and internet connectivity using this
travel router so you know I can just
take it around wherever I want
so with that you know let's dive into it
Henry here is going to focus if we could
just focus on the rig for me please
Michael great so here this is basically
what it looks like as you can see here
there is a Raspberry Pi at the bottom
you have a sense hat on top you have the
growth I place on top of it and you have
all of the sensors connected at the top
over here and we will be interacting
with it can we please switch to my
laptop
okay first things first I want to make
sure that everything is up and running I
don't want to start a demo and find out
that everything's broken behind the
scenes because albeit this is a hack
that I've created it's not a production
quality Samsung technology you can build
this up for about hundred bucks so
anyway first thing I wanna establish is
is the process running okay so when I do
that that basically tells me that there
is a demon a process that's running on
the Raspberry Pi so essentially a demon
is a program that basically runs
constantly and the operating system
basically will restart and if for
whatever reason it dies okay now one
other thing is the the as you can see
from the status it is generating its log
files it's generating a log file here so
let me tail it so this is basically
telling me what the actual program the
Python program is doing now let me now
press the button okay you can now see
what happened I click the button the
webcam captured photo or I think of a
few objects hopefully I'm aiming
correctly the telemetry reading is
displayed in the log file it's telling
me everything from the light reading the
sound level orientation accelerometer
and a few other things it's played a WAV
file for the shutter sound to indicate
that something actually happened it's
used the FS web program to basically
capture the photo and it's uploaded the
photo to Google Cloud storage you know
which is essentially like a giant file
system sitting in the cloud so you can
just you know upload files to it and not
worry about it because then you can you
can have the cloud handle it yeah so
that's pretty much what I've done so
let's do it a few more times
now let's try and see how Ralph is
responding to this whole thing he seems
pretty happy this is from wreck-it ralph
so there you go there you go how about
this elephant from India or this little
mermaid line from and I don't know if
it's gonna do take the Eiffel Tower
let's check and there is a horse as well
okay there you have it put them all
together Ralph in the middle let's snap
away let's take a picture of the
audience smile good one more
okay you get the drift right pretty easy
pretty obvious so what no big deal
now my colleagues might be the partners
just bear with me can you just one
moment the our partners at quantify nil
a come out in particular he's a very
talented software engineer unfortunately
he wasn't able to be here at this
conference he's come up with this
beautiful dashboard and it shows you all
the photos that I just captured okay
that's real time for you okay a cheap
little contraption with commodity
Hardware $35 Raspberry Pi and a webcam
capture photo publish it publish it at
will to the cloud and you have a cloud
function that's constantly listening to
those events and it's basically gone and
done object detection for you it's done
object detection and it's drawn a
bounding box around the object that are
detected okay and it's used a localized
object feature of vision API and it's
also used a label detection feature of
vision API to come up with a world word
cloud okay and essentially look I'm not
a machine I'm not an AI expert I'm not
into machine learning I'm just a
software engineer but I was able to
literally leverage Google cloud platform
to spin up a fairly useful practical
suspect
object detection of surveillance system
as well as an environment monitor with
little to no effort very little code
okay you don't need to have a PhD in AI
to come up with something like this
let's see if it detected anything about
you guys oh there's people here
surprised and one of them is smiling
event oh there's a convention there's a
convention there's a crowd there's an
audience that's pretty impressive let's
see what happened to be here
it's detected an Indian elephant so if
you ask me that's all pretty impressive
so this is vision API in action for you
okay it's also detected wreckit-ralph
and it's a person with muscle and
physical fitness come on tell me you're
impressed right give me some sign that
you're impressed come on thank you thank
you I'm working hard over here yeah so
you guys get it okay
the next thing I want to show you is you
get to idea about what's happened behind
the scenes vision API localized objects
which gives you the bounding box as X Y
coordinates and whatnot and also the
label detection now let's look at
telemetry stats look at how fast the
telemetry readings are getting updated
now that again ladies and gentlemen is
real-time for you okay I cannot think of
another technology that'll that is
better suited than firebase or firestore
in this particular instance where I can
just pump real-time telemetry data to
the cloud for it to get visualized in
real time just like that
move something your hand lights light oh
yeah what do you want me to do
Oh light oh yeah okay good Henry here
has a good suggestion check that out I'm
moving my hand right above the light
check out the light reading on the top
right-hand corner it's gone all the way
down and take it take my hand up 755 how
quick was that that's pretty cool right
okay look I can go on about this right
there's also there is also a B 3 d3
dashboard you know this is an earlier
version the dashboard that we created
and this also shows you things like the
ultrasonic sensor so for instance if I
moved my hand you can see the sonic
reading fluctuate okay that's real time
for you again you need to know what's
happening right this very moment across
devices across geographies as and when
it happens I can't think of any other
technology that will make it happen
other than Firestone if I press the
button how long did it take for the
button to flash instantaneous if I move
this rig see the globes move okay
that's the gyroscope and accelerometer
in action for you so that's you know we
are there most other sensors ok let's
let's look at how it's working behind
the scenes ok
this here is firebase console you know
you can go to firebase you can just look
up firebase console that is how fast the
telemetry readings are being sent by
this Raspberry Pi to the cloud you know
at one-second intervals extremely fast
here you have the accelerometer readings
and you also have light reading over
there you have the orientation with the
gyroscope
in you know readings sonic level
readings which is the proximity reading
and so forth and temperature all this
happening rapidly you know all those
photos that we just took where are they
you know this is a collection fire store
basically has this concept of a
collection and documents so essentially
in this document you have multiple
collections so you have multiple tags
assigned to that one photo so in this
particular case you can see floor
flooring hardwood and so forth
you know so it's pretty easy okay you
can also see the bounding box
coordinates these are the diagonals x
and y coordinates so that you know we
were able to draw the bounding rectangle
okay you can see what's happening here
we had events happening on the raspberry
pi it gets published in real time to
fire so the image gets published to
cloud storage cloud function kicks in it
does object detection it generates
bounding box rectangles and it does
label detection and so forth and you
were able to see all that
instantaneously four minutes left no
worries and then you also have this
thing called a cloud function okay cloud
function is basically serverless
technology you know this is basically
what it looks like so if I went into
cloud functions here you know let's look
at Python and here you have the source
and this is basically it and this is
based look Python it's trivial piece of
code I don't have time to actually go
through it but it's literally less than
hundred lines of 200 lines pretty easy
but okay this is where the fun begins we
want you all to participate in this demo
we'd like to gamify this we're gonna
give you exclusive access to two of the
most talented engineers in San Francisco
my friend Henry and Gopi over here
exclusive access to these two guys will
give you a personal personal 30-minute
session to do what you please with the
IOT rig all you have to do all you have
to do you know that card that was handed
out to you please scan the QR code or
visit next
. charms EECOM and from the drop-down
box that you see there select one or
more tags as you select one or more tags
we are keeping a tally of you know who's
clicking on what could I please get you
all to participate in this live demo
this is basically demonstrating
real-time IOT at scale in action so you
go to image so basically go to image
pull on that you know once you arrive
there and click away click away on
different labels
we have a couple more minutes if I could
please get you all to click away the
more the better the more the better
click as many times as you want because
there is a punchline to this there is a
purpose to this ok as you can see here
as you select these labels the images
get updated in you know you know
instantaneously
are we good how much time do we have
show us that's know okay let's now look
at the stats let's look at user stats
and there you have it how long did that
take ladies and gentlemen to come up
with a live histogram of all of the
selections that you made over the last
minute
that again is firestore for you who is
be volt show at go sport shop shake
there you go he's the winner so it seems
so this is getting updated in real time
thank you all for your support and I
would personally like to thank my
partners at quantify for the great work
I'd also like to personally thank my
friend and and very talented engineer in
India who wasn't able to be here nearly
Kamat but please feel free to reach out
to us at the quantified booth after this
session thanks again
[Music]